[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من الرياض
والتي نقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبار ملفات
السعوديه والخليج اليكم العناوين
الرئيس الصيني يقضي ثاني ايامه في موسكو
دعوه الى التهدئه ورئيس وزراء اليابان
يصلوا الى كييف
وزير الاعلام اليمني يؤكد لاذاعه العربيه
ثقتنا مطلقه في قياده السعوديه لاستقرار
المنطقه
التعامل
سيكون بحزم
السعوديه تعلن جاهزيتها الامنيه لموسم
رمضان محطات للنقل على مداخل مكه ولا عمره
من دون تصريح
في الرابعه ايضا
خلال ساعات عشره تبدا رحله ثراء هلال شهر
رمضان في مناطق السعوديه
مساء الخير وحياكم الله بتزاموني مع زياره
الرئيس الصيني لروسيا قال المتحدث باسم
وزاره الخارجيه الصينيه
ان الرئيس الصيني يؤكد ان هناك اصوات اكثر
سلميه وعقلانيه وان معظم الدول تؤيد تخفيف
حده التوتر في اوكرانيا وتدعو الى تشجيع
المفاوضات والمحادثات السلميه
فيما يخص القضيه الاوكرانيه اكد الرئيس
شيتنج ان هناك اصواتا اكثر سلميه وعقلانيه
معظم الدول تؤيد تخفيف حده التوتر وتدعو
الى تشجيع المفاوضات والمحادثه السلميه
وتعارض صب الزيت على النار تاريخيا حل
النزاعات يتطلب الحوار والتفاوض في
النهايه منذ وقت غير بعيد اصدرت الصين
ورقه الموقف بشان القضيه الاوكرانيه داعيه
الى حل سياسي للازمه
اعلن رئيس الوزراء الروسي ميخائيل مشوستين
الناموسكو ستعزز التعاون الاستراتيجي مع
بكين مشيرا الى وجود مشاريع حكوميه بقيمه
165 مليار دولار بين البلدين وقال في
اجتماع مع الرئيس الصيني في مقر الحكومه
الروسيه بان اولويات التعاون ستشمل
الشراكه الاستراتيجيه في قطاع النقل
والمشاريع التكنولوجيه وليس فقط شركات
الطاقه في اشاره الى 79 مشروعا يبلغ
اجمالي قيمتها اكثر من 165 مليار دولار
في المقابل وصل رئيس الوزراء الياباني
كما افادت وسائل اعلام يابانيه بعدما
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه عن توجه الى
اوكرانيا او توجهه الى اوكرانيا في زياره
مفاجئه وافاد التلفزيون الياباني العام ان
اتش كي ان كيشيدا شوهد وهو ينزل من قطار
في محطه في وسط كييف كما قام رئيس الوزراء
الياباني بزياره لبلده بوتشا ومن المتوقع
ان يلتقي كشيدا بالرئيس الاوكراني
فولدمسكي خلال هذه الزياره
تضموا الينا من موسكو مراسله العربيه
كاتيا طعمى اهلا بك معنا كاتيا في نشره
الرابعه اذا زياره مفاجئه لرئيس الياباني
الى كييف والتفاصيل حول ذلك خصوصا في هذا
التوقيت الذي يتزامن مع زياره الرئيس
الصيني الى روسيا
ونبدا نبدا بالقمه بين الرئيس الصيني وبين
بوتين كاتيا ان كان هناك معلومات متوفره
حول هذه الزياره وتفاصيل هكذا
اليوم هو الرئيس اليوم الرئيسي لزياره
الرئيس الصيني الى روسيا طبعا هناك
على الاجنده اليوم بدا لقاء الرئيس الصيني
مع رئيس الوزراء الروسي ومن بعد ذلك منذ
قليل بدات على البطاقه الموسعه لقاء
الوفود بين الوفدين الروسي والوفد الصيني
ضمن الوفد الروسي هناك طبعا وزير الخارجيه
الروسي ووزير الدفاع الروسي
بالاضافه الى ذلك كان هناك من جانب الصيني
ايضا وفد موسع يليه ايضا سيكون لقاءات
سينضم اليها نواب رئيس الوزراء الروسي ومن
بعد ذلك سيكون هناك توقيع لنحو 10 وثائق
بين الجانبين اهمها وثيقتين هو وثيقه
تعميق العلاقات الاستراتيجيه بين البلدين
ووثيقه ايضا العلاقات
الاقتصاديه والشراكه الاقتصاديه بين روسيا
والصين نعم ويعني هناك لقاء مرتقب للرئيس
الصيني مع بوتين متى سيبدا هذا اللقاء هل
من تفاصيل حول ذلك تحديدا
هو منذ قليل بدا لقاء بين الرئيس الصيني
والرئيس الروسي بالاضافه الى الوفود من
كلا جانبين سيكون هناك طبعا فيما بعد
مؤتمر صحفي كما ذكرته لك مشترك اللقاء
الوجه لوجه كان يوم امس وكان قد بحث طبعا
الموضوع الاوكراني وخطه الصين حول خطه
السلام حول اوكرانيا التي طرحتها الصين
منذ وقت سابق وكان الرئيس الروسي قد رحب
بهذه القطه الخطه التي طرحتها الصين وان
موسكو طبعا كما تحدث بيسكوف هي مستعده
طبعا لدراستها ولكن هناك شعور بان
اوكرانيا لن تستجيب بشكل ايجابي الى هذه
الخطه بسبب الضغوطات الغربيه طبعا كما
تحدث الخبراء عن ان اهميه هذه الزياره
للرئيس الصيني الى موسكو هي تاتي الان في
ظل طبعا
العقوبات التي فرضها الغرب ومحاوله عزل
روسيا بعد بدءها العسكريه بالاخص اقتصاديا
هناك طبعا محاوله لزياده التبادل التبادل
التجاري بين البلدين الى نحو بيئتين مليار
دولار والذي قد وصل طبعا حتى الان الى 190
مليار هناك مشاريع مشتركه زياده تدفق
الغاز الروسي الى الصين الذي كما تحدثت
غاز بروم قد وصل الى خمسه عشر ونصف مليار
متر مكعب في العام السابق بالاضافه لذلك
خلال لقائه لوزير لرئيس الحكومه الروسيه
هناك مشاريع نحو 80 مشروع مشترك سيتم طبعا
انشاءه بين الجانبين من بينها في قطاع
المواصلات سيكون هناك مشاريع لطرق عبر
سيبيريا وعبر اسيا فاطمه بالطبع هذا يجعل
من الصين اكبر مستورد للنفط الروسي كما
تشير التقارير كاتيا اذا زياره الرئيس
الصيني الى موسكو متى تنتهي متى سيغادر هل
من تفاصيل
هل تسمعينني
طيب شكرا لك من موسكو مراسله العربيه
كاتيا طعمه
قال سكرتير مجلس الامن الروسي نيكولاي
بتروشيه فان الولايات المتحده تستخدم
الاكاذيب والاتهامات لتشويه سمعه موسكو
فضلا عن عمليات الاستفزاز المتعمده على حد
وصفه واضاف بتروشيب في اجتماع عقد في
اوليانوفيس على ضفاف نهر الفولجا الروسي
انا واشنطن تحاول زرع الكراهيه تجاه موسكو
وفرض الموجهه معها واتهم المسؤول الروسي
البيت الابيض باستخدام اساليب قذره في حرب
المعلومات واستخدام الاكاذيب الصارخه
والاتهامات العشوائيه التي لا اساس لها
وفق تعبيره
ننتقل بكم مباشره المشاهدين الى مؤتمر
لامين عام حلف الناتو نستمع
وسنواصل العمل
بجهد لنضمن ان السويد ستصبح عضو كامل
باسرع ما يمكن لان ضم فنلندا
سيجعلهما اكثر اما
وبالتالي هذا يجعل
المساله تحافظ على امن المنطقه
والرئيس بوتين يحاول ان يسيطر على دول
الجوار وحتى
انتهت الحرب في اوكرانيا غدا الا ان
المناخ الامني تغير في كل اوروبا فغزو
بوتين العام الماضي كان صدمه
وهو
حصيله نمط متواصل من السلوك العدائي
للروسيا منذ ضم القرم في 2014 وبعدها كان
هناك
عمل دفاع مشترك لدول النيتو هو الاكبر منذ
ذلك الحين نحن دائما نؤكد اننا على اتم
الاستعداد لنقف مع الشركاء من البلطيق الى
البحر الاسود لدينا اربع الاف جندي تحتها
قياده
النيتوت
وايضا تم مضاعفه اعداد الجنود وفي الوقت
ذاته تقدمت النيتو الدعم الكبير لاوكرانيا
من خلال الانظمه الدفاعيه لمساعده
اوكرانيا الدفاع عن نفسها واستعاده
اراضيها كما اننا في عمليه
تحقيق اهداف اخرى وهي
تقديم الذخيره وايضا دفع القطاعات
الصناعيه في مجال السلاح للتسريع من
الانتاج كي تتمكن ان اوكرانيا من ايجاد
الذخيره الكافيه للدفاع عن نفسها وكذلك
هناك
حمايه
الكوابل في المحيطات وهي مهمه جدا وهي
ايضا هناك قوه عمل مشتركه اوروبيه مع
النيتو في القمه السابقه اتفق اتفق حلفاء
النيتو على تغيير الشروط الدفاع بهذا
القدر من المؤتمر الذي نشاهده مشاهدينا
لامين عام حلف الناتو ينسبك
في تصريحات خاصه باذاعه العربيه اكد
وزير الاعلام اليمني معمر الارياني ثقه
الحكومه اليمنيه بما تقوم به السعوديه من
جهود لضمان الاستقرار في المنطقه واخرها
الاتفاق السعودي الايراني الذي جرى برعايه
صينيه
اهلا وسهلا وانا سعيد جدا اليوم ان اكون
على اذاعه العربيه
ويسمحوا لي ان ابارك لكم وللمجتمع العربي
في كل ارجاء العالم
اطلاق اذاعه العربيه طبعا والتي تاتيك
اضافه نوعيه للقنوات المتميزه كانت
العربيه وكانت الحدث شكرا معالي الوزير
ونبدا بدايه في اعتقادك حديث بدا عن
التفاهمات والمصالحه السعوديه الايرانيه
برعايه صينيه هل باعتقادي كان هذه
المصالحه سوف تفتح فرصه للحل السلمي في
اليمن في البدايه نؤكد طبعا ثقتنا المطلقه
باشقائنا واهلنا في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه وما تتخذه من اجراءات وخطوات
لارسال الامن والاستقرار في المنطقه
بما في ذلك الاتفاق بين المملكه وايران
الذي تنذر على صيني
طبعا بالرغم من قناعتنا بعدم التزام
النظام الايراني
بالالتزامات التي نص عليها الاتفاق
واحترامه مبدا السياده وعدم التدخل في
الشؤون الداخليه للدول للدول
والتوقف عن دعم الميديشيات المسلحه ووقت
تهريب الاسلحه طبعا يعني هذه القناه انا
بعمل تجارب من السابقه مع
النظام الايراني الذي لا يلتزم بالمواثيق
والمعاهدات الدوليه الا اننا نامل ان يكون
قد استفاد من تجاربه السابقه
كما اكد وزير الاعلام اليمني معمر
الالياني ان المفاوضات التي انطلقت في
سويسرا تعتبر اختبارا حقيقيا لجديه
الحوثيين في الانخراط لحل الصراع
الحقيقه المفاوضات التي انطلقت قبل ايام
في سويسرا بخصوص الاسرى
والمقتطفين هي اختبار الانعكاس التوافقات
الاقليميه الاخيره على الملف اليمني وهي
اختبار حقيقي لجديه
الميليشيا الحوثيه في
الانقراض في جهود التهدئه وامكانيه في
مسار لانهاء الحرب واحلال السلام طبعا ملف
الاسرى ظل طوال الثمان سنوات الماضيه
رهن الابتزاز والتلاعب الحوتي رغم يعني
كونه ملف انساني ورغم التنازلات التي
قدمتها الحكومه
رابعه مستمره وتتابعون فيها
امانه جده تبدا بازاله التعديات على
الواجهات البحريه تشمل 110 عقارات
احييكم من جديد ادانت السعوديه التصريحات
المسيئه والعنصريه الصادره عن احد
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين بحق بحق فلسطين
وشعبها وذلك وفقا لبيان صادر عن وزاره
الخارجيه الخارجيه السعوديه اكدت موقف
الرياض الرافض لتلك التصريحات كونها تنشر
خطاب الكراهيه وتحرض على العنف وتقويض
محادثات السلام واكدت على دعم السعوديه
للجهود الدوليه بهدف حل القضيه الفلسطينيه
على اساس مبادره السلام العربيه
في ذات السياق وصف وزير الخارجيه الاردني
ايمن الصفدي تصريحات وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي وسلوكه بانها تصريحات تحريضيه
وعنصريه وتعكس فكرا اقصائيا متطرفا
كما قلنا التصريحات العنصريه التحريضيه
الاستفزازيه التي اطلقها وزير في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه
واطلاق هذه التصريحات على منبر يحمل خريطه
مزعومه لاسرائيل تضم الاراضي الفلسطينيه
المحتله وتضم المملكه الاردنيه الهاشميه
هذه تصريحات
ومواقف وتصرفات تحريضيه عنصريه
تعكس فكرا اقصائيا
عنصريه متطرفا اكدنا ادانته واستنكاره
ورفضه وتواصلنا مع المجتمع الدولي
لابراز خطوره مثل هذا الفكر الاقصائي
العنصريه التحريضي
وانعكاساته على ليس فقط العمليه السلميه
ولكن ما يرسله من رساله حول خطوره هذا
الفكر العنصري المتطرف
كشف مدير الامن العام في السعوديه الفريق
محمد البسامي خلال المؤتمر الصحفي الاول
لقيادات قوات امن العمره عن ضروره حجز
موعد عبر تطبيقين توكلنا او نسك لاداء
العمره بهدف ضمان جوده التنظيم الخطه
تضمنت وبالتنسيق مع وزاره الحج والرئاسه
الى انه يتطلب الحصول على هذا العمره حجز
موعد في تطبيق توكلنا وايضا في
تطبيق نسخ الاعداد متاحه وكافيه جدا
والمطلوب الرحمن هو التقيد بمواعيد لانها
جزء من التنظيم
اكد الفريق محمد البسامي انه سيتم مراعاه
حركه التدفقات من المحاور الخارجيه وعبر
محطه النقل العام لضمان عدم تجاوز الطاقه
الاستيعابيه الامنه داخل محيط الحرم المكي
شكل محطات
النقل العام كل عام لكن السنه هذه
الكثافات العاليه اهميه قصوى بتوزيع هذا
الكتابات على الحرم هذا العام ستكون اداره
حركه تدفقات من المحاور الخارجيه المنطقه
المركزيه بحيث تتوائم الكثافات البشريه مع
الطاقه الحسابيه الامنه داخل المحيط الحرم
المكي الشريف وبما يرفع من كفاءه
الوصول الامن والميسر باذن الله تعالى
من مكه المكرمه ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
سلطان السلمي اهلا بك معنا سلطان اذا ما
ابرز الاجراءات والاستعدادات المتخذه حتى
الان لموسم رمضان
اهلا بكم اهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه العربيه
من مركز العمليات الموحد في العاصمه
المقدسه انتهى قبل قليل
المؤتمر الخاص بقيادات قوات امن العمره
لموسم رمضان هذا العام 1444 بحضور مدير
الامن العام وعدد من قيادات قوات امن
العمره اذا اعلنوا جاهزيه كافه الخطط
التشغيليه والتنظيميه والامنيه المتعلقه
بموسم العمره هذا العام هنا في مكه
المكرمه وكذلك في المسجد النبوي نتحدث عن
خطط كبيره ومحاور ومرتكزات مهمه اعلنت
عنها قيادات قوات امن العمره في المؤتمر
قبل قليل من اهمها او اهم هذه المرتكزات
الاعتماد بشكل ملحوظ وكبير جدا على محطات
النقل العام المنتشره في العاصمه المقدسه
هذا وكذلك حافلات مكه لوصول المعتمرين
والمصلين الى الحرم المكي وكذلك الخروج
منها ايضا الاعتماد بشكل كبير على كافه
المحاور الرئيسيه المرتبطه في الحرم المكي
وتسخيرها فقط للم التمرين وكذلك تخصيص
محاور رئيسيه اخرى سوف تكون فقط هي
للمشاهده هيك عن وجود قطاعات الامنيه في
كافه انحاء المسجد الحرام وكذلك تخصيص
كافه الساحات وكذلك سحل المطاف والادوار
العلويه وايضا كذلك الاسطح سوف يتم
تشغيلها بكامل الطاقه الاستيعابيه للتعامل
مع الاعداد المليونيه المتوقعه المتوقعه
التي سوف تشهدها او يشهدها الحرم المكي
هذا العام في طوال شهر رمضان وتحديدا في
عشر الاواخر ايضا هناك خطه تنظيميه
ومرتكزات اخرى من ضمنها مكافحه الظواهر
السلبيه في المنطقه المركزيه وكذلك داخل
الحرم المكي مثل التسول وغيرها ايضا بوجود
عدد قطاعات امنيه مختصه لمكافحه هذه
الظواهر كذلك نتحدث على وجود قطاعات اخرى
في المنافذ لدخول العاصمه المقدسه والتاكد
كذلك من وجود التصاريح اعتمرنا او حتى من
خلال تطبيق توكلنا او حتى تطبيق لوسوك
لوجود تصريح للعمره كذلك سوف هنالك خطه
تنسيقيه وتشغيليه ما بين القطاعات الامنيه
وكذلك القطاعات العامله في موسم تحدث على
وزاره الحج والعمره السعوديه وكذلك رئاسه
الشر الحرمين وكافه القطاعات الخدميه
العامله في المسجد الحرام لتنظيم عمليات
الكثافه البشريه او تنظيم عمليات الحشود
لدخول الحرم المكي وحتى لا يوجد هنالك
كثافات بشريه او استحامات داخل المسجد
الحرام او حتى الساحات علما المتوقعوا
وجود اعداد كبيره سوف اشهد الحرم المكي
ذلك تم تخصيص كافه الساحات وكافه المناطق
المجاوره للحرم المكي كمصليات اخرى جانبيه
في الشوارع او بالقرب من الفنادق مقابل
الحرم المكي كذلك الساحات والاسطح وكافه
الطرق المؤديه للحرم المكي سوف تكون هناك
مسارات المشاركه سوف يتم تفعيل الدائري
الاول لاول مره كذلك سوف يتم تفعيل انفاق
جرول في منطقه الشماليه محرم المكي لسوف
يكون هناك كذلك محطات تردديه من والى
الحرم المكي عبر مسارات مخصصه ايضا سوف
يتم التعامل مع كافه المعتمرين القادمين
من خارج العاصمه المقدسه ووصول الى الحرم
المكي سوف تهون عليك محطات توقف سوف
يستطيع المعتمر القادم من خارج مكه ايقاف
مركبته وصعود هذه الحافلات عفوا علما الم
من المحطه وصول الحرم المكي لا تتجاوز 16
دقيقه انا هيك انا ادوار مهمه كذلك يعمل
على يعمل عليها الدفاع المدني السعودي
نتحدث على 5000 جوله رقابيه تمت خلال
الشهر الماضي والشهر ما قبل الماضي للتاكد
من كافه المرافق الخدميه وكذلك الفنادق
المجاوره بالحرم المكي من سلامتها وتوفير
كافر السلامه بسبب عدم حتى لا يكون هناك
سمح الله وقوع حرائق مستقبلا كذلك كافه
القطاعات الامنيه تعمل وفق غرف امنيه
موحده لتسهيل المعتمرين المصلين خلال شهر
رمضان نعم
في غربيه السعوديه بدات امانه توجد
بازالته تعديات الواجهات البحريه بعد قرار
تضمن الغاء الصكوك عليها مع فتح الواجهه
البحريه للعامه ويجدر الذكر بان الصكوك
الملغى تقدر بنحو 110 صكوك وحجج استحكام
على بحري جده بعد ثبوت استخراجها بشكل غير
نظامي وتعود ملكيتها الى امراء ووزراء
سابقين ورجال اعمال وسيدات اعمال
مشاهدينا على ما يبدو هناك صور مباشره
للرئيس التركي وهو يستقبل رئيس الوزراء
العراقي محمد شياع السوداني الذي يزور
تركيا في زياره رسميه ننقل لكم صور مباشره
لهذه الزياره ولاستقبال ومراسم استقبال
رسميه للرئيس طيب اردوغان يستقبل فيها
رئيس الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع السوداني
نستمع على الصوت الطبيعي لهذه الصور
[موسيقى]
نشره الرابعه مستمره وتتابعون فيها
الرابعه توفق اخر ايام التقريشه او
التقريشه في حائل شمال السعوديه تقليد
سنوي يسبق رمضان
[موسيقى]
الرئيس الصيني يقضي ثاني ايامه في موسكو
دعوه الى التهدئه ورئيسه الوزراء اليابان
يصل الى كييف
وزير الاعلام اليمني يؤكد لاذاعه العربيه
ثقتنا مطلقه في قياده السعوديه لاستقرار
المنطقه
التعامل
سيكون بحزم
السعوديه تعلن جاهزيتها الامنيه لموسم
رمضان محطات للنقل على مداخل مكه ولا عمره
من دون تصريح
خلال ساعات عشره تبدا رحله طائره هلال شهر
رمضان في مناطق السعوديه
حياكم الله من جديد على هامشي المنتدى
الانسانيه الاوروبي في العاصمه البلجيكيه
بروكسل التقى المشرف العام على مركز الملك
سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه الدكتور
عبد الله ربيعه التقى مدير عام برنامج
الامم المتحده الانمائي اكيم حيث بحث
الطرفان الشراكه الاستراتيجيه وسبل
تعزيزها فضلا عن مناقشه الملفات المدرجه
في المنتدى الانساني الاوروبي كما ناقش
الدكتور عبد الله ربيعه ووزيره الدوله
ونائبه الوزير للتعاون التنموي الدولي
والتجاره الخارجيه السويديه سبلة تعزيز
التعاون لتقديم العون للفئات المحتاجه حول
العالم
في السعوديه تستعد وزاره الثقافه لاطلاق
موسم رمضان لمده شهر من خلال فعاليات
وانشطه ثقافيه ورياضيه ويتضمن الموسم
فعاليات مستوحاه من الثقافه السعوديه ذات
الارتباط الوثيق بروحانيه شهر رمضان منها
فعاليات باب البلد في جده التاريخيه
وانشطه متنوعه في الرياض تشمل مسابقه حفظ
القران الكريم وركن القهوه السعوديه
ودكاكين الحرفيين وعربات الاطعمه والمقاهي
ودكاكين وبسطات الحلويات الرمضانيه
بالاضافه الى جداريات الرسم التفاعليه
وغيرها من الفعاليات
للمزيد ينضم الينا في الاستوديو المتحدث
الرسمي باسم وزاره الثقافه عبد الرحمن
المطوع اهلا بك معنا استاذ عبد الرحمن
يعني فعاليات يبدو انها جميله جدا لهذا
الموسم ربما هي الاول من نوعها حدثنا عنها
اكثر واي المناطق تشمل وكم من فعاليات
سيتم عرض خلال هذا الشهر
في البدايه الشكر لقناه العربيه على اتاحه
الفرصه للحديث عن موسم رمضان كما اشرتم
احنا في وزاره الثقافه نستعد هذه الايام
لاطلاق موسم رمضان ابتداء من اول ايام
الشهر الكريم يمتد الموسم طيله الشهر
ونعمل من خلال الموسم على ابراز الجانب
الثقافي المرتبط بشهر رمضان الكريم
واجوائه الروحانيه يقام العديد من
الفعاليات
والانشطه الثقافيه المتنوعه خلال الموسم
على امتداد شهر رمضان الكريم
موقع الصحيح تقام الفعاليات باكثر من 38
موقع
وكما ذكرت فيه 14 مدينه حول المملكه حجزنا
في وزاره الثقافه على ان يكون هناك تنوع
في الانشطه المقاومه وكذلك اماكن عقد تلك
الفعاليات ابرز المدن التي ستقام بها
الفعاليات السيد عبد الرحمن والمناطق كذلك
بالتاكيد طبعا
على سبيل المثال لدينا في مدينه الرياض
عدد من المواقع الرئيسيه لاقامه تلك
الفعاليات لدينا احد المواقع الرئيسيه في
الموقع
الواقع بجانب مركز الملك عبد الله المالي
يقام فيه فعاليه خيمه رمضانيه
الفعاليه تتضمن انشطه عديده ثقافيه يقدم
فيها على سبيل المثال في تلك الخيمه يقدم
وجبات رمضانيه وجبات الافطار والسحور كذلك
يقدم عدد من الانشطه
الشعبيه يتاح فيها ويتواجد فيها عدد من
الاسواق الشعبيه والمعاصره يوجد فيها كذلك
مواقع لممارسي المهن التقليديه والحرافيه
هل من مواقع بالاطفال ربما ايضا يوجد كذلك
انشطه مخصصه للاطفال ومواقع كذلك يقدم
فيها عدد من سواء الانشطه الترفيهيه
والالعاب المخصصه لتلك الفئه بالاضافه الى
انشطه
لكافه افراد الاسره على سبيل المثال عندنا
فعاليه قرقيعان المعروفه تقام في منتصف
الشهر في عده مواقع على شكل واسع جدا طبعا
حنا نتحدث عن الرياض ولكن ايضا هي تشمل
جده وتشمل 12 مدينه او 11 مدينه اخرى كذلك
من حول المملكه تشمل نفس الفعاليات والهدف
منها تحديدا هو ابراز الثقافه وابراز يعني
العادات والتقاليد اللي نعملها او تتخذ في
السعوديه عاده في شهر رمضان طبعا في جده
باعتبارها بوابه الحرمين الشريفين في
منطقه جده تاريخيه تحديدا يقام العديد من
الانشطه الثقافيه ويضاف لها عدد من
المعارض اقامه المعارض المتخصصه مثل معرض
المصحف الشريف وكذلك لدينا معرض تاريخ جده
ومعرض
المساجد التاريخيه هذه المعارض مصاحبه
لتلك الفعاليات والانشطه الثقافيه وش
هدفكم الاخير
من هذه الفعاليات اللي ستقام خلاله طبعا
نعمل في الوزاره على اقامه الموسم من اجل
ابراز الجانب الثقافي المرتبط بالشهر
الكريم وكذلك احياء الموروث الثقافي
المرتبط بشهر رمضان الكريم بالاضافه الى
خلق تجربه ثقافيه مميزه لكافه افراد
المجتمع وجميل استاذ عبد الرحمن ربما
حتكون تجربه تفاعليه للاطفال ترسخ لديهم
يعني هذه الفكره فكره الاحتفاء بحلول شهر
رمضان وفكره العادات والتقاليد التي تتخذ
خلال هذا الشهر الفضيل مجهود تشكرون عليه
سيد عبد الرحمن مطوع شكرا لوجودك معنا في
استديوهاتنا في العربيه بالرياض شكرا لكم
تقريشه عاده اجتماعيه متوارثه منذ سنوات
طويله في مدينه حائل تقام في اواخر شهر
شعبان من كل عام وجرت في مثل هذه العاده
استحضار الاكلات الشعبيه الحائليه التي
اشتهرت بها المنطقه الزميل جزاع النماصي
شارك بعضا من الحائلين هذه المناسبه
ووفانا بهذا التقرير نتابع
[موسيقى]
التجريشه تقليد شعبي شهير في مدينه حائل
شمال السعوديه وهي عاده اجتماعيه يحرص
الكثير من الاهالي على احيائها بدءا من
منتصف شهر شعبان وحتى قبيل شهر رمضان من
كل عام
[موسيقى]
مثل هذه الليالي يجتمعون يتبادلون المؤن
وكذلك يتبادلون الزاد ثم بعد ذلك تطورت
شيء فشيئا حتى وصلت الى انه كل الاعمام
تجتمعون حالهم الخوال اهل الحي
القريبات تجتمعون يعني ويحتفلون بها احدى
الليالي سعاده لقرب شهر رمضان المبارك
وكذلك توديع للاحبه والصفاء للذهن وصفاء
للود اللي بينهم وكذلك يعني اذا كان هناك
بعض الضغائن وبعض الشحناء اللي بين الناس
انه تروح
جرت العاده في مثل هذه المناسبه على اعداد
الاطعمه الشعبيه الحائليه التي اشتهرت بها
المنطقه كالمكشوش والثريد والعصيد الى
جانب الهريس والتمن والجريش فضلا عن طبق
العاده الكبسه النقطه الاساسيه ليست
بتكلفه وانما الاهتمام الدقيق في عمليه
الطبخ انك تعطيها النفس الحقيقي هذا
الميزه ترى الاطفال الصغار يلبسون مسرح
يتزين يمحن حقاقش وين يوزعنه على بعض
احيانا تعطيهن مثلا انت مثلا على ريال
الريال اذا شفت المراه البنت الصغيره مثلا
زينه والله والله جانا اربعه خمسه تجمع
ليش تجمع من الان خش للعيد
[موسيقى]
هذه العاده القديمه كانت تقام حصرا لابناء
لعائله الواحده او في نطاق الحي عادت في
السنوات الاخيره لتشمل شرائح اكبر وعلى
نطاق اوسع بهدف الحفاظ على هذا التقليد
المتوارث منذ سنوات طويله
من مدينه حائل جزاع النصي العربيه
شهدت كليه الملك فهد الامنيه حفلا تضمن
تخريج الدفعه الرابعه للفرد الاساسي
للنساء والذي حصلنا من خلاله المتدربات
على كافه برامج امنيه او كافه البرامج
الامنيه ذات كفاءه عاليه واحترافيه فائقه
وفق احدث اساليب التعليم والتدريب
[موسيقى]
هذا وكشف العقيد صدام الفارس مدير معهد
التدريب النسائي الامني ان اعداد خريجيه
دور التاهيليه الرابعه للفرد الاساسي
للنساء تصل الى 600 متدربه في عدد من
القطاعات الامنيه
احتفلنا اليوم بتخريج 600 متدربه لعدد من
القطاعات الامنيه بعد ان تلقين العديد من
المهارات الميدانيه والعسكريه والمعرفيه
التي تعلن باذن الله على اداء واجباتهن
بكل كفاءه اقتدار ما شاهدناه في احتفال
اليوم هنا تاج التدريب الجاد من قبل
متدربات اسال الله ان التوفيق والسداد
لخدمه الدين ثم المليكه والوطن
بدات عشره مراصد لترائيل الاهله في
السعوديه بتحري رؤيه هلال شهر رمضان لهذا
العام ودعت المحكمه العليا في السعوديه
ايضا ممن يراه هلال رمضان بالعين المجرده
او بواسطه المناظير ابلاغ اقرب محكمه اليه
وتسجيل شهادته اليها او الاتصال باقرب
مركز لمساعدته في الوصول الى اقرب محكمه
الثراء ويرصد جميع المعلومات من خلال هذه
المراصد في السعوديه معي الان الرائي متعب
البرغش وهو من المترائين الدائمين في مرصد
تمير اهلا وسهلا متعب في البدايه التوقعات
لرؤيه هلال شهر رمضان هذا اليوم من عدمه
والظروف
في الاجواء وغيرها بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
خرجنا اليوم تلبيه نداء المحكمه العليا
لتحري هلال رمضان 1444 وحسب المعطيات او
المعطيات الحسابيه لمرصده الاهل لابتمير
ان الشمس سوف ان الشمس سوف تغيب في تمام
الساعه السادسه وثمان دقائق حسب احداثيه
المرصد ويغيب قبلها القمر في تمام الساعه
الخامسه هو 57 دقيقه والاصل في ذلك الرؤيا
وهي تبدا في تمام الساعه السادسه وثمان
دقائق ثم نسجل الاحداث في في رؤيه الهلال
هل تمت رؤيته او تعدل رؤيته ثم عاد ترسل
الى المحكمه العليا وهي الجهه المخولها او
المختصه بذلك في اعلان دخول الشهر او
اكمال الشهر نعم متعب الان انت كرائي ماذا
تحتاجون هل الراي يحتاج الى تدريب دوري
لكي تبقى هذه المهاره لديه مهاره رؤيه
الهلال نعم لازم المتراعي
يتدرب على بعد النظر وايضا
يقرا يكون عنده معلومات مهمه بذلك في غروب
الشمس وفي شروق الشمس وفي غروب القمر وفي
شروق القمر وايضا
تكون المناطق تكون صخريه بعيد عن التربه
والغبار يعني مكان مفتوح على مد النظر هذا
تدريب لبعد النظر هل انت كرائي معتمد من
قبل معتمد حكوميا يعني وايضا المده التي
تعمل بها في هذا المجال كم نعم حنا من ضمن
الرؤات المعتمدين لدى المحكمه العليا او
من ضمن اللجان ومرصده ميل من ضمن المراصد
المعتمده ولله الحمد
ونخرج في مرصد تميير لنا الان ما يقارب
180 شهر نحضر كل نهايه شهر هنا في المرصد
هو يوم 29 واليوم الذي يليه
ودائره الاهله في المحكمه العليا وضعت
طوابه لها وضعت لها موقع في الكتروني في
وزاره العدل الجمهور كل شهر يقدرون يطلعون
عليه ويشوفون هل دخول الشهر او لم يتم
دخول الشهر او تعذر رؤيته وهذه تطور عظيم
ولله الحمد كل الشكر لك متعب ونحن سنتابع
معكم رؤيه هلال رمضان من عدمه اذا فاطمه
ايضا هذا المرصد بعد تقديم شهاده رؤيه
هلال رمضان من عدمه في تمام الساعه
السادسه وثمان دقائق بتوقيت الرياض ايضا
هناك مرصد عشر مراصد ستقدم الشهادات تباعا
واخر هذه المراصد هو مرصد منطقه تبوك الذي
سيقدم ايضا شهاده الرؤيه من عدمها للمحكمه
العليا ومن ثم تتخذ المحكمه قرارها ويرفع
القرار النهائي الى الملك سلمان ويصدر
بيان رسمي بهذا الشان سواء ان يكون غدا هو
اول ايام رمضان او يوم الخميس هو اول ايام
رمضان
شمال غرب الرياض مراسل العربيه نواف عزيز
شهر رمضان لهذا العام اوله قران ثالث وفي
نهايته بدايه الحرب الفعلي التفاصيل في
تقويم مع خالد ازعاج
[موسيقى]
الشهر التاسع من شهور السنه الهجريه يسمى
بشهر رمضان ورمضان من الشهور العربيه
القديمه سمي بهذا نسبه الى رمز الارض اذا
اشتدت حرارتها فكان يقع في شده الحر وقت
التسميه ويسمى بشهر الصوم وشهر الغفران
وربيع الفقراء كنايه عن كثره العطايا
للفقراء خلال هذا الشهر كعطايا الربيع لنا
بشتى انواع النباتات فهو شهر المحبه
والالفه وله سلوكيات اجتماعيه ونمط حياتي
مغايرا عن الشهور الثانيه الصوم ليث وانا
الذي اجزي به صدق الحديث وصح عنه تعالى
صوموا تصحوا قالها خير الورى وبذلك اوصى
صاحبه
والاله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ورمضان لهذه السنه في اوله هجران ثالث
واللي اهلنا الاولين الله يرحمهم يقولون
جراند ثالث ربيعا ذلك وفي نهايته بدايه
الحرب الفعلي وفي منتصف هجره الطيور
عالميا شكوت الى سرب القطا اذ مررنا به
فقلت ومثلي بالبكاء جدير اسر بالقطع هل من
معير جناحه لعلي الى من قد هويت
اطير
[موسيقى]
في اليمن ومع الظروف المعاشيه الصعبه
والنزوح لا غنى لليمنيين عن توفير متطلبات
شهر رمضان من المواد الغذائيه والتموينيه
وللتخفيف من معاناتهم دشنت الحكومه
اليمنيه ثمانيه معارض رمضانيه للبيع
المباشر مع تواجد القطاع الخاص معارض شهدت
عوده للمنافسه وتخفيض اسعار متطلبات شهر
رمضان
تتجول رغد مع والدتها واخوتها داخل معرض
الشهر الكريم الذي نفذته المؤسسه
الاقتصاديه اليمنيه لتوفير احتياجات
اليمنيين من المواد الغذائيه والتموينيه
باسعار مخططه ازدحام كبير شهده المعرض
الذي عاد فيه القطاع الحكومي لمنافسه
القطاع الخاص في بادره هي الاولى منذ بدء
الحرب
بين
التجار نفسه واللي خارج طبعا في منافسه
هذا ما بين التجار وما بين الحكومه باشياء
بسيطه طبعا كلها فارق اسعار يعني ما تزداد
عن ميه مئتين طبعا شي جيدا وتحصل مثل هذا
المنافسه في مارب والاول مره التنافس داخل
سقف واحد في ثمانيه معارض رمضانيه بينها
مارب المدينه الاكثر ازدحاما بالنازحين
وفر لليمنيين فرصه الاستفاده من شراء
متطلبات شهر رمضان باسعار اقل من السوق
المحليه خصوصا تلك الاصناف التي توفرها
المؤسسه الاقتصاديه كل المنافسه الان وكل
التخفيضه الزياده الذي
الاقتصاديه يعني المراه الظروف الاقتصاديه
التي البلد القمح والارز والسكر والزيت
والحليب حرص القطاع الحكومي على توفير
كميات كبيره منها لضمان استمراريه انخفاض
اسعارها كمواد اساسيه لا غنى عنها في ظل
حاله معيشيه صعبه يعانيها المواطنون
بالنسبه للمعرض بدايه خير ان شاء الله وفي
اسعار مناسبه
نقص البور نقص والمواد الغذائيه ان شاء
الله انه بدايه خير وبدايه منافسه حلوه
بين التجار ان شاء الله يكون مبشره بخير
من معرض مؤقت الى معارض بيع مباشره دائمه
تؤكد الجهات المعنيه سعيها لتوفير المواد
الاساسيه والتموينيه للمواطنين ما يضمن
كسر الاحتكار يامل المواطلون ان تنعكس
المنافسه بين القطاع الحكومي والقطاع
الخاص في انخفاض اسعار المواد الغذائيه
والتموينيه بشكل اكبر في ظل الظروف
المعيشيه الراهنه محمود الحميدي العربيه
مارب
ختام رابعه نذكر بالعناوين
[موسيقى]
الرئيس الصيني يقضي ثاني ايامه في موسكو
دعوه الى التهدئه ورئيس وزراء اليابان يصل
الى كييف
وزير الاعلام اليمني يؤكد لاذاعه العربيه
في قتنا مطلقه في قياده السعوديه لاستقرار
المنطقه
التعامل سيكون بحزم السعوديه تعلن
جاهزيتها الامنيه لموسم رمضان محطات للنقل
على مداخل مكه ولا عمره من دون تصريح
عشره مراسم تبدا رحله ثراء هلال شهر رمضان
في مناطق السعوديه
نهايه الرابعه في امان الله
[موسيقى]